blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman we're now more than a week into
joe biden's presidency there are
certainly things to criticize for
example joe biden said two thousand
dollar checks are going out right away
if democrats win the two georgia seats
they haven't now it's not clear exactly
what will be in the covid relief bill
it's not exactly clear when
uh that is going to be happening so
there's no question that there are
criticisms here but if we take a
sort of fair and comprehensive
uh approach to the question how does joe
biden's first week
compare to donald trump's four years i
would make the case and i would feel
confident making it that joe biden has
done more good in his first
eight or nine days in office eight days
in office i guess it's been
than donald trump did in his entire four
years a lot of this has to do with the
virus
the coronavirus task force being re re
uh invigorated uh bringing in actual
qualified doctors increasing vaccination
we're already up to 1.2 million vaccines
a day
figuring out where are these
discrepancies in terms of vaccines
getting vaccines out to people
number of vaccinating locations going up
dramatically
starting to be very clear about the
possible trajectory
trajectory of the virus that alone is
absolutely huge
but then you look at pausing the arms
sales to saudi arabia
and the united arab emirates reversing a
lot of the bad decisions made by donald
trump
including joe biden getting us back into
paris climate
back into the who reversing the
trans-military ban
working to promote racial equality
through executive orders after donald
trump did whatever he could
to get rid of any executive orders that
said hey we should really look at this
or we we should really look at that
um starting to actually put together
some potential progress on immigration
which has been
so it's not just that the discussion's
been fraught
but it's been such a failure under the
trump administration
looking at um environmental
regulations that are put back in when
they were once trump undid via executive
order
but also canceling keystone xl
pipeline i could go on and on and on
with the list but the amount that he has
been able to do
in these first eight or so days
really is more of a counterbalance
to donald trump's four years than i
could have ever
imagined and my promise to you when joe
biden
even before joe biden won and then when
he won and then when he was confirmed by
the electoral college and when he was
inaugurated is that
we are going to keep joe biden
accountable to the promises that he made
but when joe biden does things that are
good i'm going to tell you that he did
good things it doesn't mean he's perfect
it doesn't mean the democratic party
is now a bastion and beacon of
progressivism it simply means
that sometimes presidents do things that
are good and
they should be applauded for that and i
think what has been
most fascinating to see about this is
that
the country seems to see it joe biden's
first approval rating 63 percent
higher than donald trump's approval
rating at
any time during his presidency remember
that donald trump
never even hit 50 percent at any time
during his presidency and presidential
approval
joe biden already at 63
uh 69 approval of joe biden's handling
of coronavirus
in these early days 80 81
approval of joe biden's federal mass
mandate and
and national mask sort of request i
think is the right way to call it so
we are in a very polarized situation 25
28 30 of the country is off the deep end
in terms of radical
ignorant politics as i call it so when
you consider that
these really are very very good numbers
for joe biden and we are going to
continue tracking
uh his promises and what he does
but the first seven eight nine days
uh i am very pleased with and i'm even
yesterday we had a voicemail from a
bernie supporter who said
i voted bernie but i i have to tell you
i'm pleasantly surprised by a lot of
what's going on and and i do believe
that
in terms of the most pressing thing
what's happening with vaccinations is
excellent and i hope that we can soon be
at two two and a half million vaccines a
day
on the other side someone who's not
doing so well
donald trump's property values uh have
plummeted
it's insane what is going on with donald
trump's property values trump
branded manhattan buildings have lost
half of their value since donald trump
first took office
properties that used to have the trump
name but don't anymore
have lost 17 percent of their value
it is believed it seems
that the trump brand name is a disaster
right now and i am wondering whether at
some point in time
if he doesn't already donald trump is
going to regret
or end up regretting this entire
presidential run and presidency uh urban
digs
looked at the seven luxury buildings in
manhattan that have the trump name
and three that used to be trump branded
buildings but had the trump branding
removed and
they are all doing disastrously and
what's hilarious about this to me
is that we've covered over the years
donald trump's funny business with
property valuations we know that when
donald trump wants a loan
or a line of credit against one of his
properties
he will inflate the value of the
property and claim it is worth much more
than it's really worth
on the other hand when donald trump is
trying to minimize taxes
uh or to uh for other reasons benefit
from lower property values
he will just argue that his property
values are much lower than they probably
are
in reality uh it seems as though donald
trump is going to have no problem
arguing for lower property values for
the upcoming years
for tax purposes because they really are
collapsing and
in in some sense i mean the the trump
we've talked before about how trump
spent his life essentially trying to
stay away from the people that make up
the vast majority of his supporters
i know that trump has some wealthy
supporters but a lot of the folks that
support trump
are the folks from the parts of the
country
that trump has never been a big fan of
and people who economically
are not the people that donald trump is
trying to spend time around
and in that sense his presidency has
been terrible marketing for his business
the people
who like trump can't afford
to live in his buildings many of them
can't even afford to go to donald
trump's hotels which by the way are also
looking quite
uh sparse not exactly bustling from
videos that have been released
lately pandemic understood certainly a
factor
so in a sense uh trump's constituents
from a presidential
standpoint are not the folks that are
trump's business
customers and that may well prove to be
yet another disaster
as things go forward just to put some
numbers to it back in 2016
the average price per square foot at
seven of trump's properties
was around thirty three hundred dollars
per square foot very very high
and in 2017 that was down to nineteen
hundred dollars a square foot in 2020
it was 16 a square foot and who knows
now where those numbers are going to be
bearing in mind
part of the decrease is less about trump
but about
what's going on with the virus
potentially
but luxury properties have not been as
affected as some other areas of the
economy so
i don't know what the answer is in terms
of if you got an honest answer from
trump do you regret running for
president has this all been a disaster
for you
we know that ivanka and jared are not
particularly welcome back in new york
city we saw the wanted posters
all over manhattan when it was revealed
that they were hoping to go back to new
york city after the end of donald
trump's reign of terror in washington dc
if you got them in a room and and they
were really honest with you and i don't
know if they would be
to some degree it's hard to imagine that
they're that thrilled
i mean i think on the one hand it's sort
of a balancing between on the one hand
these are narcissistic uh people
and there's a thirst for power where
it's so
appealing and attractive the presidency
and being at the white house and all of
that
on the other hand the social circles
they were part of are widely speaking
shunning them the people that want them
around or the people
they tried to stay away from their
entire lives and
their businesses while still functioning
businesses may now be number one
worth far less and far less profitable
than they ever were
and they are going to be dealing with
investigations uh
into all sorts of possible financial
wrongdoing for the next
very many years i don't know how great
the entire presidency and politics
experience has been for the trump family
and i'm not sure if they they are even
coming clean with themselves about it
never mind whether they would come clean
with someone in a room if they knew
it wasn't being recorded what do you
think what do you think is the trump
family's
honest perspective on what this
presidency has done
for them let me know you can find me on
twitter
at deepakman and you can find the show
on twitter at david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you
do it's called blinkist and what they do
is take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's hear from some folks via the
david pakman show discord
davidpakman.com
discord we hope that the uh discord gods
will look upon us
favorably today and that we have uh good
connections and
auspicious uh conversations let's go to
javi from dc first javi from dc you're
on the air
oh david can you hear me yes i can and
my own voice is echoing back so ideally
you would be
maybe listening in headphones or turning
down your speakers
sorry i was just in a zoom class
actually let me try to fix that
wow we're interrupting class that's wild
okay is that better it is okay
um so i was wondering um
do you think that there's the uh the
republicans are gonna have their own
version of bill clinton in a sense that
due to i guess branding issues they're
going to want to have a candidate that
moves
them to the left the same with a bill
clinton furthermore democrats to the
right
you know like a republican that says you
know what
obamacare is the free market solution to
healthcare you know
what we're gonna legalize drugs and try
to center all those
you know now it's kind of a centrist
policy
but i think there's a market for like
progressive policies but framing right
redirection
do you think that that's something
that's going to happen or something
that's possible well you know i i'm not
so sure that
i understand that by today's standards
bill clinton is no progressive but
i i'd have to think more about whether
in 1992
bill clinton moved the democratic party
to the right is that is that what you're
saying as part of your premise that in
92
clinton was a rightward move for the
democratic party that's that's a while
ago
that's true um in any case i mean with i
think that there's more to explore there
but let me focus on your main question
i think the answer is it's too early to
know and
it really comes down to do republicans
learn anything from the trump fiasco how
will we be able to tell well we'll be
able to tell
when we look at like do marjorie taylor
green lauren bober and madison cawthorne
do they end up being one-term wonders
and immediately voted out in 2022
or do they get second terms that would
be a signal about what the republican
party thinks it needs at this point in
time
does sarah huckabee sanders riding on
being trump's former press secretary
win the gubernatorial republican primary
in arkansas
do ivanka or lara trump or any of them
run successfully for something i think
we don't yet know what the republican
party will think it needs to do
well then let me entertain this do you
think that there's
um and i've seen this a little bit with
you know like joe scarborough talking
about
medicare for all i've heard kyle
kolinsky talk about that um
and how he his rationale is that it
actually is
uh you know a set of policies that
maximizes freedom maximizes
individualism maximizes entrepreneurship
so he centers a progressive policy
within a sort of like right-wing
direction you can see that with like
marijuana
um people that are pushing for
legalizing drugs yep um
you know it's it is the more
liberty-oriented quote-unquote position
i was wondering do you think that
there's the possibility that
candidates that have i guess that
viewpoint of
hey i'm not doing things just i'm not
doing things just because i guess like
the
donor class or like elites that are you
know entwined with
politicians want something i'm doing
these things because one they're good
for people
and that's the whole question of you
know how you craft a society
and then two it actually fits within
conservative like you know i value yeah
markets i value individuals i value
family and
taking these ideas that are progressive
and then maybe
having more still like a free market
approach to that so this isn't
this is not a new idea with this is the
idea of
um appealing to your typical political
opponents
by framing your positions in ways that
appeal to
their values and you and i aren't going
to be able to
figure out whether that is or isn't a
good idea today there's a lot of
scholarship
on you should like for example uh
the you're making a perfect perfect case
here the the liberty argument with
something like
cannabis even if that's not the reason
why the left supports legalization
we can appeal to the right by you by
framing it as an issue that appeals to
their values
the first question is whether that's
effective and there's a lot of debate
about that the second question is
whether
the you know the problem with it is that
a lot of modern conservatism is not
really motivated by liberty they claim
to be but they really aren't they're
actually very authoritarian
and as george lakoff writes they
subscribe to something called
strict father morality which is if you
do something bad
your dad has to punish you for it even
if you can justify it in some way
and so i i i would want to think more
about that i
i'm not so sure okay but anyway david um
uh i actually uh heard about strict
father
uh i forgot the third word but like the
strict father
kind of like political theory or
whatever through uh hearing you on joe
rogan
so thank you for putting me on that that
was really interesting um
but i'm going to let you go but i do
want to thank you one last time
because this time last year i was in a
government class with a teacher that
didn't teach very much
and you know i was also voting for the
first time and
your channel and other channels kind of
helped you know help me understand
issues and
uh beautiful discover different policies
and some political philosophy so thank
you for that david
thank you i really appreciate it and i
hope to uh to speak
to you again uh very well said
i like that let me go to kelsey from
colorado
kelsey from colorado welcome you are on
the air
david good to speak with you again
likewise
hey uh so i was thinking about this
um and i kind of want to get your
opinion i just watched your video
on uh to get uh
conspiracy theorists and i thought it
was fascinating
and um while i don't
i i my personal kind of experience
with it is um with a friend who was
um conservative in 2016 but
has then switched now to libertarian
okay but
uh a conversation we had uh marched
right before
everything shut down um was conspiracies
um linked to um
kind of the government with how funding
works
um i know a lot of her stuff with states
rights
um with in terms of libertarianism went
in there
and um especially and then when the
pandemic hit it became a
well we're getting microchips this is
you know we get a vaccine or
well the government just forced to stay
in and
we have to be you know enclosed but you
know i'm gonna go partying
um yeah that sounds less libertarian
than conspiratorial to me
yeah and that's what i'm getting from it
and so i guess
my question is what way do you kind of
engage with somebody that is like
you know they can't claim to be very
libertarian like they go
to conference with like ron paul and
like you know
say all that but then they're spewing
all these other conspiracy theories
that necessarily correlate with each
other well the two things aren't
necessarily related things
you we have to deal with conspiracy
theorists the way we know we are best
able to deal with conspiracy theorists
which is ask them
about the sources of their information
ask them
how many people would have to be
involved in keeping that quiet for it to
work
ask them how they determine whether a
news source is trustworthy
follow their conspiracy through to its
logical conclusion whether they happen
to also claim to be libertarian or not
i'm not so sure that i even see it as
relevant
sure yeah that makes sense yeah i just
think it was um
i find it fascinating because she's his
friend has
changed their uh political affiliation
but has still kept some of the
kind of wacky things that you would see
on the right is what you're seeing now
so yeah i just found it
find it very interesting but uh you know
the other thing to keep in mind is
i'm not saying libertarians don't exist
they certainly do
but there's a lot of people who claim to
be libertarians or to claim or claim to
be libertarian or liberty-minded
conservatives
who will very quickly become
extraordinarily authoritarian
when they see that the libertarian path
leads to things they don't like and so
a lot of these libertarians aren't even
really libertarians and so i
i think it's all always important when
someone has a libertarian awakening
some people really do but some people
don't they just found a label that they
prefer while still being very
authoritarian
that makes sense cool well thanks david
i really appreciate your time
all right thank you kelsey from colorado
great to speak with you again
um let's see why don't we go next
to uh why don't we go to amugo
from florida
hey dave can you hear me yes i can well
it was good talking to you again i
remember we talked during the uh
georgia runoffs indeed yeah
um i guess mine is a question slash a
rant
like i'm just listening to um these
republicans and how they're talking
about oh we can impeach the president
a former president now we should move on
this unity thing to keep talking
it's honestly driving me crazy because
it's like
you just saw what the president did he
incited an insurrection
democrats saying hey let's hold him
accountable and the republicans are
going
well we need unity you know we don't
it's already divided as it is and it's
like
it just it's blowing my mind how they're
this man
even though he's not in office and just
yeah it's a terrible argument i mean one
i saw rand paul earlier this week say on
tv
you can't impeach a president who's no
longer in office
that that's not only untrue but remember
trump was impeached while he was in
office the impeachment is what happens
in the house what happens in the senate
is the trial
and either an acquittal or or a
conviction so these are a combination of
opportunists
and propagandists and people who don't
actually even have any interest in
sticking to the principles they claim to
hold very dear
and my approach is increasingly the
bernie approach bernie said
over the weekend listen anything we can
do via budget reconciliation
without a single republican if we
determine we should do it and it's good
for the country we're going to do it
uh we're not going to find 17
republicans to convict donald trump
okay well then then that then they won't
but that'll be them on record and we're
going to go through the tri i just think
we
they're they are so disingenuous with
when they want unity and when they don't
and when obstruction is acceptable
just get around them any way that you
can
yeah like i like i feel like with like
the left and the democrats i feel like
our issues are you know policy like
we're trying to say hey democrats push
for 15
minimum wage push for universal health
care push for
efforts on climate change i feel like
the right is doing
you know who's more sycophantic to trump
like right um kyle kolinsky said this
bet
i don't know if he reported it or
something but he said that on the day
fox news called the election for joe
biden like
pretty much the majority of the fox news
viewers just fled fox news and went to
newsmax one american news their safe
space
yeah it's not it's not the majority it's
not the majority fox has seen a downtick
but you know majority means over 50
percent
but i think you know the proof is in the
following
look at the people that just got
themselves elected most prominently
riding on the trump wave madison
hawthorne marjorie taylor green lauren
bobert and those types
what what is the big policy that they
care about what are their big policy
positions
it's about owning the libs and riding
the trump wave and saying
we're not going to be communist and
social
it's completely vapid yeah
um one more thing before i let you go um
i don't do you know who brian
is by any chance did you say brian tyler
cohen
yeah yes i do i do yeah so him
and tommy larry on the issue as they did
a debate before the i think was before
after
i think was after the election and the
the moderator asks
oh if democrats control the senate um
what's going to happen yes brian tyler
cohen this and by
how cohen said oh 50 minimum wage access
to health care climate change listed a
bunch of things i'm like
oh that sounds really good then he goes
so tommy landon goes
oh if the republicans control the senate
what's what's gonna happen and she just
said stop socialism
that's like stop social yeah yeah i mean
there are other republicans who would
have other answers but that is that is
the epitome of
of what's going on right now politically
it's just unreal
anyway uh thank you appreciate i kind of
want to get that off my chest appreciate
it
all right thanks amugo amugo from
florida let's take a quick break if
you're holding to talk to me please
don't hang up
because we're gonna go right back to the
phones momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right let's hear from a few more
people via the david pakman show discord
server at
davidpakman.com discord let's go to keon
from north carolina keon you're on the
air
hey hey david how you doing good how are
you
how's it look good oh yeah so um
my question i want to ask you is um
i'm curious about like what you think
about
um what are your foreign policy views
and i'm gonna be more specific please um
with regards to how
if you was president how would you deal
with north korea
with north korea yes well
first first of all
that's a it really depends on what's
going on
at the time notice that since the
pandemic
no one's hearing a peep out of north
korea there was a little bit of a period
where supposedly they had no cases and
of course who believed that they might
have had no testing
but they they certainly had some cases
as insular as they are they still did i
there's not one answer to how to deal
with north korea because north korea
goes through these waves where they
become very belligerent often when they
need
food aid and they threaten this and they
threaten that
and then things get very quiet as famine
kind of rolls in
so i i think the things that would be
important for dealing with north korea
in my mind would be
you can't be naive the way trump was
into thinking
that when kim jong-un or whoever tells
you they're going to do a b or c that
they're really going to do it north
korea has been making these same
promises
to global leaders for decades now
they never do this stuff they will
slightly lower their belligerence
when they need something so the first
thing is
i would be thinking about north korea
independent of what they say
when they're in desperate situations and
then as a general approach i would
probably be thinking of how to work with
south korea uh on how
what what possibilities are there to try
to
normalize circumstances to some degree
and the degree to which north korea
wants it is
is a real question mark but i think the
first step is i wouldn't be giving north
korea
the publicity of the singapore summit
with the handshakes and all of this
stuff
you know former american presidents have
understood that that's a huge propaganda
value to them
and they didn't do it whereas donald
trump fell for it and he did and we
really got nothing out of it
yeah i agree with dom i agree with you
it's just
my my issue is one of the things that
bothers me is they keep unveiling these
missiles
and um they are they are
invading international sanctions by like
trying to
go into cryptocurrency and stealing
financial information
and i mean at this point like my concern
is worth the south korean people
the north korean people hold on hold on
you're concerned for the south korean
people or the north korean people
well i'm concerned for both yeah okay
yeah it's just that
ultimately i don't think that i mean
there are
there are they are going to negotiate in
good faith
ultimately i think eventually
um what's going to happen is like
my this is a hypothesis okay i don't
know if this is true right
my my concern is they're going to build
up those weapons
and then they're going to try to take
over south korea
and yeah when we try to go and help them
they're going to threaten us with
you know nuclear um
their ability to do that that that would
take them a very long time
and without taking a position one way or
the other
i don't imagine the us or or south korea
will allow that to happen
so i i actually i'm not as concerned
about that full-scale scenario that that
you're talking about but it's an
important issue
some but i don't know i just i think
that
i mean i mean and then i also thought
about
i was talking to a a scholar like you
know he's
his um perspective on international
relations is realism and i said well why
don't we just
allow south korea to develop nuclear
weapons
so then that would be like a you know a
counterbalance to their nuclear weapons
yeah i just don't think that that's
really a solution particularly when the
range of these weapons at this point is
is quite a bit bigger than the korean
peninsula but let me think a little more
about that
kion from north carolina very much
appreciate the call and great to hear
from you
let's go next to uh
alex from south carolina you're on the
air
oh hey david yes it is uh yeah uh so i'm
from south carolina obviously
and um i listen to a lot of polit uh
political radio and as you can imagine
it's mostly right-leaning
yeah and from what i've heard from colin
since the election
um i don't know if you know who uh tom
rice is but
he's a senator that represents my
district or
congressman excuse me okay i've seen
uh collins from radio shows that are
basically threatening to primary him
because he voted for impeachment so
what i'm concerned of is in the next two
to four years are we just gonna see a
bunch of
like radical trump-like uh characters
come from
all these reliably safe republican
districts
and i'm afraid that the republican party
is just gonna get a lot more radical
i don't think it's clear that that's
going to be the case i think it's
possible
i think it's possible but that the one
direction is the one you describe which
is
green beaubert and cawthorne get
re-elected in 2022
along with a whole bunch of new sort of
trump q anon cultist types that's one
direction
the other direction is if donald trump
just keeps his mouth shut i mean we
haven't heard from him essentially for
the 10 days since he left office
if he just keeps his mouth shut and more
traditional republicans regain
influence in the republican party then
you may see the trumpian
members of congress lose re-election in
2022
and no one else get into power so i
think your
fear you're right that it could happen i
don't think i'm ready to say that that's
the direction things are going we have
to wait and see
really hope you're right cause i'm
terrified of where that party's headed
well i'm not sure i'm not saying it
won't be that way but i'm just saying i
don't i don't have enough information
yet to say one way or the other
unfortunately it's just going to be a
wait and see i just want to say thank
you for taking my call
and i've been really excited to see your
growth on twitch over the last year
thanks so much i appreciate it
all right take care very good uh yes bit
powerful powerful growth
is happening on uh on twitch for sure
let's go to magnus from
scotland magnus from scotland you're on
the air
magnus from scotland please unmute
yourself so that we can talk you're on
the air
and last opportunity for magnus from
scotland you were on the air
all right that's too bad i always uh i'm
thrilled
to hear from our scottish
callers why don't we go to nick from
tennessee next nick you're on the air
nick from tennessee you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey uh thanks for taking my call my
question is actually about
the stock market um it's something that
i've taken
interest in um mainly after
reading matt tybee's journalistic work
on the
2008 financial crisis and
learning more through the documentary
capital in the 21st century
and my question for you is is it
am i overestimating the impact that
the stock market and financial market
has on our
system or is it something that doesn't
get talked about due to the sort of
inaccessibility of it
and how hard it is to enact change um
well you might have to say a bit no i i
think um
i think many people accurately
understand the impact of the financial
system the stock market being a piece of
that
on our political system um you you know
maybe you could be more specific in
terms of the ways you think are not
appreciated enough but i think anybody
who's paying attention to the political
space in a serious way understands
that the financial system is
inextricably linked to the political
system both in terms of how the
financial system funds the political
system uh but also how
it has created sort of this revolving
door
of regulatory capture where you have
the regulators and the industry leaders
and the elected officials
all together and often going from one
role to the next
is there a specific way you think it's
underappreciated
i it's tough because i'm just learning
about it so i'm i'm still sort of
finding excuse me the vocabulary to um
to express you know my concern with it
but
yeah in learning just the history of
um how the stock market essentially
took over the economy um as soon as it
was introduced or created
in you know around the time just after
industrialization in america and the
fact that it has sort of remained this
very powerful presence but doesn't seem
to ever
enter the uh the political arena of
discussion
at least on on the level of public
discourse which we hear
from most media sources yeah i think i
think to some degree you're right
i mean i do think that there's a
superficial analysis
of if the stock market's up it signals a
good economy
and if it's down it signals a bad
economy and of course the stock market
isn't the economy and stocks are
disproportionately held by a relatively
small
percentage of people certainly the vast
vast majority of the shares
uh but i think i would agree with you
that there's not a deeper analysis of
the connection between the stock market
and
and the political system that that maybe
you would be useful but i do think most
people are at least generally aware
of the role of the stock market and and
how publicly traded companies
generally speaking operate
that's fair and um like i said i'm still
learning and
and new to this world but it's just
something that has really intrigued me
lately um and just one final question
for you
and i've learned through watching your
content that you participate in the
stock market um
what is your i guess stance on it as a
participant
um from our you know the ground level of
being just a consumer who is also
involved in stocks and investing yeah so
this isn't financial advice
advice but as i've said before uh you
know my
my full-time thing is not picking stocks
and making investments and even the
people who do that full-time
often underperform the market averages
so i'm not
arrogant enough to think i'm
particularly good at picking stocks
so my approach is dollar cost averaging
regularly buying
more and more shares of low cost index
funds
which you can get for you know sometimes
five basis points meaning 0.05 percent
fees nope
not paying any managers one one and a
half percent
fees for for managing a hedge fund just
go with the lowest
price index funds and then within my
portfolio maybe
three to five percent of my money is in
individual stocks that i have some
knowledge of so for example people know
i bought tesla stock six years ago
and i have a few other individual stocks
but my approach as a participant is
i'm busy hosting my show running a
business i devote
very little time to picking stocks and
i'm just buying the broader
index funds and paying as little as
possible in fees
cool uh thanks a lot for taking my call
i really enjoy your show
and i look forward to more all right my
pleasure nick from tennessee great to
hear from you
uh why don't we check in with uh
oh i don't know maybe uh david from uh
the united kingdom david from london
you're on the air
hi can you hear me i can hey um
it's so great to talk to you i've been
following you for about a year now
pleasure
um i had a really dying question
during the uh election which
i guess it was more of a difference
between how the uk run their elections
and the americans
yes and i found it so bizarre the way
results came out piecemeal like bit by
bit
because in the uk we kind of announced
the results when everything's been
counted
right and uh it just struck me as so
bizarre that
trump kept talking about massive dumps
and
went to bed and he was up and then he
was down i
really didn't understand why the u.s
system was like that
and i just yeah it was just a dying
question i was
speaking with one of my american friends
about thing and he didn't understand why
either and
yeah i mean i don't i don't have an
answer as to why
other than to say that it's been this
way for a long time i i'm
i don't know if you could even restrict
i mean listen you know
as we have 50 states and the states
collect results from the individual
counties and and municipalities
um i just don't know if you could even
could you even tell everybody do
not release any information until i i
just don't know it it is though it is
sort of strange
um it is like it would be
it would have it would have stopped this
whole kind of uh
angle of you know fox news saying oh
when 11 p.m
you know it really wouldn't and here's
why it wouldn't prevent it here's the
problem david
imagine that there's a there's a
different system where
the numbers are announced when they are
final
when it's really close like it was in
georgia
if they said hey we have it's been
eight days we now have the results then
trump and fox news and others would just
say
eight days that's really suspicious i'm
sure they spent that time manipulating
the numbers so it actually wouldn't
solve the problem
i guess you're damned if you do damned
if you don't essentially
yes they're always going to have some
kind of opinion against why it's not
correct
absolutely um yeah i just wanted to say
again like
been following you for about a year and
i i honestly i come home
after work well i mean i'm mainly
working from home but i come back and i
think around 8 9 p.m
your show kicks in i actually start your
live stream have it in the background
tab
when the music kicks in although lately
the music hasn't kicked in that much
which i've been a bit disappointed
we're doing more live stream music
lately we've got some new good new good
new tracks we've been streaming
you know i could be watching something
else or eating dinner with my girlfriend
and i'm right right i'm sorry i have to
stop
well i appreciate it i appreciate it
what uh what part of london are you in
generally
so i live in catford county which is a
part
i work in peckham which you may or may
not know
uh south london again so this is all
this is all
south of the river right i'm south of
the river
yes understood i did go to a pub in a
working uh uh sort of a a blue i don't
know what the right term is working
class blue collar i don't want to say
the wrong word
aries south of the river
with my cousin when i was in london and
it was quite an experience it was sort
of like a soccer pub i guess i would say
okay yeah fantastic well i mean if
you're
if you're next in london i don't know if
we can even travel between the us
and the uk right now i guess you can't
but if you're ever in london and wanted
to do a talk or anything like that i
would definitely be
the one to come and watch you give a
lecture or something like that and i'm
trying to spread the word to my uh
colleagues and friends around about you
and how you
uh do these live streams and yeah i just
think it's really great
my friend actually um he'd never seen
someone
i live tweet and live stream before as a
kind of way to like put out content
he found the whole thing kind of
fascinating and i've kind of got him
into watching you now and i send all the
links out to my friends when
when you come on it's really great well
thank you i i appreciate the support
from across the pond
all right thank you very much there is
david from london england
that is all the time i have today for
calls via discord
i'm sorry i wasn't able to get to
everybody but we will take calls again
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well
read about him
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get into audience questions
for the week as we see more vaccines
roll out
surpassing 1.1 and even 1.2 million
vaccines per day over the last few days
which is
fantastic to see although there's much
more acceleration that still needs to be
done
i'm getting more and more questions like
how long will mask wearing continue
the answer to this question is so
complicated because
first of all many people never started
wearing masks
there are people who still just aren't
wearing masks mask enforcement
varies drastically in different states
within the us
and in different countries but i think
the best way to
get into this topic is to understand two
things
number one how long mask wearing
continues will in great part depend on
how well different countries regions or
states are handling the virus
the mask wearing will be necessitated by
the virus continuing to spread
and and uh kill people so the places
that best and most quickly deal with the
virus
will most quickly be able to get away
from mass wearing now that being said
the more and to be clear none of this i
am
i don't pretend to be an expert on this
i have just been gathering the opinions
of
experts on mask wearing the cultural and
medical ends of the
pandemic are likely not to coincide
the medical end would be herd immunity
has been reached
and the are not of this virus
has come down to some very low level
and uh that is likely to happen
after the numbers are low enough that in
particular
um people who are not at huge risk
who have been vaccinated are ready to
say i am going back to life
sort of as normal um the other
thing that's important now when that
will be
if vaccination continues i think i'm not
saying this is right
but you are going to see dramatically
decreased mass usage probably by summer
in a lot of areas for folks who are at
risk
and who are going to remain more careful
for a longer period of time or
indefinitely
the masking in large crowded areas may
not stop for years and that's part of
what we were talking about
last week with nicolas christakis about
there's a psychological and societal
impact here where
during flu season there was a risk to
going out without a mask for older folks
and folks with compromised immune
systems
it was always there but it was not
talked about in the terms it's talked
about now with coronavirus
even after coronavirus is quote dealt
with
you may have folks in those categories
who simply during flu season
are wearing a mask anyway because they
recognize that the level of risk that
was always there is no longer
comfortable without a mask
that remains to be seen i do think it's
important to mention
that mask wearing first of all globally
the united states is somewhat unique in
that there has been such a large
political movement that considers
wearing a piece of cloth over your face
when around other people
some kind of massive imposition on
liberty and freedom
um the trump administration
definitely uh resisted
mask wearing in order to downplay the
pandemic
it was a pretty unnatural argument to
sustain when you saw how other countries
were handling it
and many other countries were sort of
confused why
why are there so many americans who
think just putting a piece of cloth over
your face
uh is is something you should resist it
just reduces the chance of spread we
don't know exactly by how much we can
debate and study exactly how much it
reduces it but
if it reduces it at all then it seems
like a good idea
it was not the political issue that it
became in the united states elsewhere
um but regardless it's still quite
popular in the united states look at
early numbers early polling about joe
biden's actions on coronavirus about 80
percent of the country agrees with joe
biden's mass mandate which remember it's
it's only a mandate
for federal uh buildings and federal
workers and on
uh interstate transportation like trains
and planes
within states and at normal places of
employment and out in downtowns
it's still up to governors to enact and
enforce
and um it's more of more of a mask
plea than it is a mass mandate but it
still has 80
support so i think that we are going to
see
widespread mass usage continue certainly
through the first half of 2021
whether it should or not if vaccination
continues and cases go down and deaths
go down
you will see reduced masking
particularly in warmer
areas by the summer i i think there's
almost no doubt that you are going to
see it i'm not
advocating for it i'm just saying that's
likely to be the case
and of course we we are going to see
that the economy is very closely paid
attention to
if you see uh more in-person
things happening um although at first
it will likely all be as long as people
are wearing masks
i think that relatively quickly you will
see people drop the masks for better or
worse i'm not advocating for it but
that's sort of the trajectory that i'm
anticipating next question today is
david how do you think that these
conspiracy theorists and reactionary
republicans in congress
are going to impact the next couple of
years yeah this is a really good
question
i actually have a sort of backwards
reverse
approach to this which is uh if we see
i'm guessing that this viewer is
referring to people like
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
congresswoman lauren bober
a congressman madison cawthorne who we
saw earlier this week just he doesn't
know anything he can't answer simple
questions
i believe that whether they get
re-elected is going to
signal to us the legacy the staying
power of trumpism and what i mean by
that is
bobert green cawthorn and some of these
others
they rose to the house of
representatives in november
riding on the winds propelled by the
same
sails that defended trumpism the
trumpian cult
and they were running in the right
districts where these sort of q anon
types like marjorie taylor greene and
the wild pro gun folks like bobert and
cawthorne
they were able to win because of the
districts in which they ran
and sort of lifted uh by the boat of
trumpism with trump
gone now and a question we haven't heard
from trump since he left office
we'll see if we hear from him during the
next two years whether these people get
reelected in november of 2022
will signal whether trumpism died with
trump
and became relegated to basically
internet conspiracy theories
or whether it will have the staying
power to maintain a sort of legislative
power
and a presence in the house of
representatives if you're not familiar
with some of these people marjorie
taylor-green for example she represents
georgia's 14th district
she has been a q anon supporter she
talked about
some shooting being a false flag i don't
remember if it was parkland or
sandy hook uh this is a really insane
person who on january 21st drafted
articles of impeachment against joe
biden uh
some of these folks are merely
delusional some of these folks are
hungry for power
and they see playing these trumpian
characters as the way to get that power
some of them plan to use it to grip
their way to something
beyond being members of the house but
this is going to be the big signal as to
whether the republican party really eats
itself
or whether it says okay yeah listen
these people were in aberration they won
because of trump but we're going
to get them out in 2022. and i don't
know the answer to that
i have no advice for the republican
party what i do think is clear
is if you lost if in a two-year period
between 2018 and 2020
you lose the house of representatives
you lose the senate
and you lose the white house with a
president who makes himself a one-term
president
you would think you would say it's time
to learn something from this
there's many things democrats should
learn as well i'm not saying democrats
are exempt from learning from what
happened
but if republicans learn from this then
they will figure out how to get these
people out
and to go back in the direction of you
know people like mitt romney
uh but but the truth is given the
popularity of ted cruz for example
and louis gohmert and matt gates even
before these whack jobs were elected in
november
it's not clear that there's a big
appetite for the republican party to do
that so
we'll see what happens but i think the
legacy of the republican party will be
in how it deals with and this applies to
both voters and the party apparatus
itself
how do they deal with these wacky people
that were elected in november marjorie
taylor green up there lauren bobert
madison cawthorne
i think there are others those are the
three names that come to mind right away
hey david what do you think the legacy
of donald trump will be
these questions are tough because it
really you need time to pass
to be able to say but if the george w
bush presidency is any indication
sometimes you can tell pretty quickly
what do i mean by that
when george w bush left office my belief
was his legacy would be
um squandering the goodwill that came
after 911 by invading the wrong country
iraq in response to the 911 attacks
and then dramatically escalating
domestic surveillance
and privacy uh incursions with the
patriot act etc that's what if you said
on
obama's day one what is george w bush's
legacy going to be
i would have said that it was that and
that is essentially what george w bush's
legacy has been
so sometimes you can tell right away if
you ask me today what will trump's
legacy
be i think it will be trump as the
ultimate buffoon who mishandled kovid
and ruined relationships around the
world even the ruined relationships
around the world may fade
as joe biden restores those
relationships but really
the covet failure inciting a riot
being impeached twice and being sort of
a buffoon
strike me as what are most likely to be
donald trump's
uh legacies when when people talk about
a president the first thing you often go
to is what were the big failures with
george w bush it was you invaded the
wrong country after 9 11. that styx
that's legislation aside tax cuts okay
yeah bush did a little bit of tax
cutting and then taxes went up a little
under obama and down a little bit under
donald trump
i don't think that's going to be the
stuff of legacies trump would like the
wall to be his legacy
he just didn't build it claiming to have
built it doesn't make you
doesn't make it a legacy if you didn't
actually do it unless you can trick a
lot of people
when you think about what is trump's big
failure my mind goes to his complete and
total failure
of handling and of leadership around
coronavirus
the capital attack because it's not even
a failure it's actually a misdeed
he incited the riots at the capitol
that will be there and then i do think
from a demeanor standpoint
being this buffoon so easily triggered
the thinnest skinned president we've
maybe ever had
who you know was enamored with
authoritarians and ruined relationships
with our historical allies
and then in pop culture it
seems that he will be sort of seen as a
nixon type for a little while except
trump impeached twice rather than nixon
who resigned he'll be sort of the butt
of jokes
and the the the go-to the meme of the
delusional dumb
corrupt president but over time we will
see
those are my instincts and he will be
seen as a one-term president who
accomplished
nothing in terms of solid legislation
um and who who did some really horrible
things
now what you know what about barack
obama what is it
what is barack obama's legacy i'm
curious to hear from you
for me obama's legacy is obamacare
president during the legalization of gay
marriage
and unfortunately scaling up drone
warfare that's what i think about when i
think about barack obama
and unfortunately when you do three
bullet points you miss a lot i mean you
what the intangible value of barack
obama
making the u.s more respected around the
world than it had been in a long time
compared to donald trump making the u.s
tragically not respected around the
world that's more of an intangible
that's hard to put on a list but i do
think that under barack obama that that
certainly was
one of the important things but does
that show up on a bullet pointed list no
it's obamacare at the top drone warfare
tell me what else what else would be
under obama's legacy those are my
thoughts right now
let me know your answer to the primary
question which is
what will the legacy be of donald trump
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com if you want you can
use the coupon code better21
to save a huge amount i won't even tell
you how much better 21 is the coupon
code
we'll see you on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman